[Applause]
all right Billy Ikea and his co-star
Luke McFarland in the movie Bros which
is such an important movie to us I think
it's the first time we've ever actually
been able to send our entire audience to
a screening before the show so you could
thank you thank you
we're so invested in this film because I
think it's going to be a huge success
this is a genre so near and dear to my
heart produced by Judd Apatow who is the
king of the male rom-com as far as I'm
concerned
um but back to what we left on the
commercial break for Luke give us the
details that the first thing you ever
said to Billy was you look angry yes in
fact those are the first words that
Aaron says to Bobby when we meet and it
was my audition scene so the first thing
I got to say to Billy icon was you look
angry yeah and I said I hear you're
boring yeah because those are the lines
Luke and I did not know each other
before he came into audition it was very
nerve-wracking uh Billy Eichner is you
know brilliant and funny and hilarious
and I came into a room and Judd Apatow
was sitting there and Nick Stoller and
all these Executives and stuff like that
so I I kind of I kind of had a little
bit of that Aaron energy where I was
sort of protecting with my sort of like
kind of saying a not super nice thing to
somebody but it sort of it was how I was
feeling too I was very nervous and I
think yeah when we are nervous we
sometimes don't have the most uh
generous things to say to people yeah
well that's how Bobby and Aaron when
they meet they both have their defenses
up you know they're both trying in
different ways walls right and they
express themselves very differently my
character is very outspoken at one I
don't want to give it away but this
becomes an issue with Aaron and Bobby in
the movie especially when Aaron's
parents visit yeah right
um because I'm a big personality and
Aaron is very drawn to that but also a
little scared of that one of my favorite
moments in the film if I may which is
you're in the museum This Is Us the
museum has so much Merit because it's
about telling people's stories and for
me that is a welcome mat that is
non-divisive that's just our history you
can't change it we need to talk about it
and we need to listen and hear about
these stories and yet your character is
looking at himself in the museum and
your placard card just starts to erase
I was so haunted so beautifully haunted
by that moment what were you trying to
tell in that moment as the writer and
the filmmaker why is the name getting
erased what do we do in order to sort of
erase our potency and our our Mark in
the world yeah well um my character in
the movie is working on what we call the
first national lgbtq plus History Museum
which is about to open right and we
don't talk a lot about lgbtq history
right and lgbtq people often don't know
our own history because it's been a race
that's not talked about in schools it's
not part of the the common cultural
conversation so we don't grow up knowing
about all the lgbtq historical figures
and what our contributions were which I
think has more of an impact on us than
we realize and that's under threat again
right exactly it's still something we're
very much dealing with and so when his
character and Luke as an actor bring so
much to this scene also but um when
Aaron I bring him to see the museum for
the first time and he walks around and
and finally sees all the contributions
of lgbtq people throughout history in
this hallway of Legends we call it that
I'm walking him through and then he sees
an empty display and sees his own
reflection and his and in his head sees
the card which for all the other
historical figures describes their
contribution to history and he realizes
that I think his card and his mind ends
up saying Aaron Shepard worked out a lot
hated his job did CrossFit right as if
that was his contribution to life and
he's realizing in that moment that he
hasn't had the type of full life he
hasn't contributed as much as he could
or he actually wants to deep down and I
think that really shakes him up although
ultimately inspires him I think it also
is such an advocacy for go out there and
live a life create stories write your
chapters make it rich we get one shot
here on this planet that we know of
um I um but it's hard and it's scary you
know it's hard and it's scary and I
think on every level we're continuing to
be challenged to sort of live bigger
live full or live more honestly I I it's
just frightening and even if you do you
can feel self-conscious about it of
course because that's not for everyone
and I'm not sure there is one way
anybody is supposed to be other than who
they gosh darn are and have that be okay
yeah and absolutely as long as you're
not hurting people yeah as long as you
are gentle and kind I am convinced we
are here to take care of each other on
this planet and for those who don't
subscribe to that we can keep our
distance from but I just think you guys
have really done such an extraordinary
job in this film of bringing everybody
in in what I believe will be a Timeless
classic oh wow thank you very much
now in the spirit of Rose I was
wondering would you guys play a game
with me of course okay good okay
it's a Twist on never have I ever but
we're calling it Rose or Rose hello look
at that
okay all right here's how it works I'm
going to read a scenario and if you've
done it you can drink oh okay and uh
maybe tell me a quick story behind the
story okay all right um sent a dirty
text to the wrong person
oh
I don't I don't I I was I was going to
send a progress picture to my trainer
because he was very concerned that I
look a certain way
um so I think I was standing in my
boxers in my bathroom and I sent it to
my best friend accidentally oh wow sent
it to Keith oh you did that's not that
dirty well it's not that dirty but it's
dirty and it's Keith it's safe let's
drink anyway yeah okay
delicious have you ever embellished you
know to impress a date
oh yeah sure yeah
given or received a lap dance
this is funny being on this talk show
when I was a kid I saw Donahue I saw the
Chippendale dancers on Donahue he talks
about that and it changed my life yeah
totally changed my life I was like I
like something about that
couldn't quite identify but I did
remember telling my parents I wanted to
be a stripper wow wow that Magic Mike
happened and they didn't call me yeah
but in Bros you strip down a lot I do
strip down a lot well that's actually
our next question for the game have you
ever been nude in public
we're pretty naked in the movie we're
pretty naked yeah it's public like I
has anyone ever built anything from
scratch
I am a woodworker it is my hobby and my
passion that's not a joke he's actually
a woodworker I am actually
you're not checking every box Luke like
seriously I've watched pictures of your
woodwork first of all it's beautiful
craftsmanship
[Applause]
and like Meet the Fockers like you're a
serious like you've come up where you're
like I just like whittled this Hoopa out
of like oh yeah
it's a great hobby to have honestly I
think especially in you know movie
making and acting what we do is so
ephemeral and then to be able to
actually go into my garage I opened up
my big door and it smells like sawdust
and I get to make something that lasts
forever and that's very different than
what we do as an actor I feel the same
way about take out food and post I get
off work and I'm like what did I order
what am I watching I've literally never
turned on the stove in my kitchen
he's building doors
well I would like to propose a toast
to a beautiful film that comes out in
theaters today which will be a Timeless
classic and open up the doors for many
people in the future you are building
something very powerful and everlasting
here and you guys built it you're the
makers of it so actually you do build
things yeah
[Applause]
[Music]